I was born and grew up in Denmark and these are countries where the government
spends taxes and spends approximately twice thelevel of the United States.
And while I am very sympathetic to many of your spending proposals,
especially on the things you mentioned on early childhood and single-payer and the like,
I alsoknow that these are countries that heavily tax everybody.
Not just the rich people, middle classes
they have consumption taxes on everything of 20%
So while I'm very sympathetic to what you say, my sense is still that you would like to spend as
a Scandinavian but not taxed as one. Is that correct?
We have the answers and you raise some very good points...
Comparing the US with Europe and countriesin Europe would be naive, over-simplistic and offend a bunch of people.
Land masses are complex but
I'm going to go ahead and compare them anyways,
because some of the comparisons between Europeand the US remain way too superficial.
"Read my lips: no new taxes"
It's not uncommon to obsess over the usualsuspects for why the US is less equal than Europe
and also has less good quality affordable socialprograms.
The analysis is simple: the US has more billionaires and taxes them less.
Europe has lessbillionaires but taxes them more.
a larger tax base to fund popular social programs and also lessinequality just raise the taxes on the rich like the Europeans do.
Now although the tax rates for
rich people explain some part of the difference it doesn't explain enough.
Europeans can afford good
social programs because a lot of Europeans pay a lot for them, mainly through indirect taxes.
AndEuropeans are also more equal before taxes even factored in because a lot of the social programsthey pay more for also reduce pre-tax inequality.
Where Americans deal with a sales tax at theirfinal point of sale, Europeans deal with a VAT
which is a consumption tax that taxes atmultiple steps across entire supply chains.
This means that a lot of things in Europe willbe more expensive but that public money can be
redistributed towards social programs that willreduce before tax inequality even more.
But the US has so far been unable to adopt the same. Why? Well, in part because taxing the wealthiest of society
is easier to advertise and justify than taxingeverybody a lot more.
In Europe, most people don't really need to be convinced about paying for their
welfare states
because it works sufficiently for most of them.
But in the US, there's an intimate
struggle with deciding whether pre-distribution will be a state local or federal solution.
Partof the reason is that in the US the federal government gets the most media attention whilestate and local governments can avoid scrutiny.
This means that minimum wage hikes in the US arepractically always seen as a responsibility for
the federal government, which has to delicatelybalance different costs of living like laborers
living in New York City and minors living in WestVirginia.
In Europe though, a country like France or Denmark can offer different geographicallysensitive policy while also being held more
directly into account because the assignmentof responsibility is clear to its citizens.
"There's this definition of a wicked problem whichis circulating around in the literature which
suggests that a wicked problem is wicked if it hasso many dimensions to it that you can't go at one
angle to the problem and try to fix it and I thinkschool finances like that so school districts get
money from their local communities in the formof property taxes. They'll also get money from the
state and the state might give the money throughmultiple formulas and then a portion a much
smaller portion about 9 or 10% comes
from the federal government so even if you try to
solve the problem at say, the state level, there arethese other funding sources that come with their
own restrictions which ultimately affect how themoney gets used in schools."
In Connecticut, a US state, the school in Bridgeport will be poor byvirtue of being surrounded by poor properties
while school in Greenwich will be richer becauseit is surrounded by richer properties.
This is because local taxes are largely funded by propertyvalues in the area.
However this concept fails to explain everything.
Educational disparities alsoexist across Europe and within its countries
The US is not unique for having a system thatpredisposes poor children to poor resources.
Education systems are complex. Finland is not thesame as Sweden. And resources invested in education
and the quality that follows does not seem likea linear relationship.
The US' unique situation is that its quality does not match the
amount that the US actually spends on it.
One of the problems with answering why resourcesdon't match the quality you would expect in the US
is because the decentralized nature of
school districts makes it pretty difficult
to actually identify what spending works and whatdoesn't.
Overall there are some indications that compared with Europe the amount of staffing, the associated health and retirement benefits
alongside transportation all add up to morecosts for the American education system.
But the differences don't end there.
"In the 1990s,as the crime rate was plummeting, as American life was getting safer and safer,
Americans freakedout and thought that if they take their eyes off their children the children will be abducted.
The fear was stoked by cable tv in the 1980s, there were a few high-profile
abductions but it's not until the 1990s that
we really start locking kids up and saying"you cannot be outside until you're 14 or 15."
We took this essential period of childhood fromabout 8 to 12 when kids throughout history have
practiced independence, have gotten into adventures,have made rafts and floated down the MississippiRiver.
We took that period and said: you don't
get to practice independence until it's too late,
until that period is over."
Kids in the USare raised differently than kids in Europe.
Some blame the planning that produced moreisolated American families,
some the over paranoia towards kidnapping in the 1980s,
and others pointto an increasingly competitive environment
where parents try to give their children an edge overthe others by helicoptering them.
It's really not that far stretch to say that many Europeanchildren could be considered to have more freedom at an earlier age.
American children are lesslikely to be able to walk to school alone compared with European children,
which you can of courseconnect to overall crime rates and authoritative school policy
is still much more accepted across
the US than it is in Europe.
"So the real key to...
the distinctiveness of America
is the structureof our government one part of it of course is the independence of the judiciary
but there's a lot more. There are very few countries in the world for example that have a bicamerallegislature.
England has a House of Lords for the time being but the House of Lords has nosubstantial power
they can just make the Commons pass a bill a second time.
France has a senate,it's honorific. Italy has a senate, it's honorific.
Very few countries have two separate
bodies in the legislature equally powerful.
That's a lot of trouble as you gentlemen
doubtless know to get the same language
through two different bodies elected in adifferent fashion.
Very few countries in the world
have a a separately elected chief executive. Sometimes I go to Europe to talk about separation
of powers and when I get there i find that allI'm talking about is independence of the judiciary
because the Europeans don't even try to divide thetwo political powers, the two political branches:
the legislature and the chief executive.
In all ofthe parliamentary countries the chief executive is the creature of the legislature,
there's neverany disagreement between them and the prime minister as there is sometimes betweenyou and the president.
When there's a disagreement they just kick them out, they have a no-confidencevote a new election
and they get a prime minister who agrees with the legislature
And you knowthe Europeans..."
The difference is simple: European countries are mainly nations not federations.
AEuropean state, if it existed, could never be the same as the US.
Written in their constitution, US
states are modeled after the federal government
and state governments, which mirror the one above, usually have their own chamber of representatives,
a senate and also have an executive mirroredafter their president
In Europe, if there was any state that was above the countries that
made it up,
it would have to be modeled from those very different countries beneath it
ratherthan serving as a model for the countries below it.
This is an important difference because itmeans that any kind of European government
would have to balance parliamentary systems withpresidential republics, federal states with unitary
ones and they'll be expected to create a systemthat hopefully pleases each one sufficiently.
All in all, although the differences
between the two are practically endless
and some are near impossible to actuallydescribe, it's still a worthwhile effort
to try and figure a few out and also discussthem.
In some way, Europe has more breathing room to understand what it wants to be,
which is noeasy task because whatever you think Europe is,
it can still look across the Atlantic and realize what it definitely is not.